est ce qu'au final ce meizu 16 est
intéressant est ce qu'il faut l'acheter
oui ou non et puis au final pourquoi
choisir plutôt qu'un autre alors c'est
toujours un peu compliqué parce que
[Musique]
regarder ce truc regardez ça regarde et
je sais pas si ça vous parle
c'est l'objectif de mon gh5 c ou en tout
cas c'était mon objectif leica
voilà donc si vous êtes curieux vous
voulez savoir à quoi ressemble
l'intérieur donc voilà ça ressemble à ça
il a fait une chute à cause d'un pied un
peu pourri pieds sur lequel est posée
tout de suite elle la caméra faut pas
que ça bouge sinon je vais mourir parce
que c'était pas prévu ça de le changer
voilà donc les boules bon aujourd'hui on
n'est pas là pour parler de ça ni pour
se plaindre bien au contraire on est là
pour parler d'un produit que j'ai reçu
il ya quelques temps qui a dormi pendant
un long moment studio parce que j'étais
à las vegas et à new york
on le rappelle c'est ce produit là c'est
le meizu 16 mai ou sixtine suppose brest
vous avez le petit ph
rappel les cours d'anglais la cours
d'anglais à l'eau mais où s'expriment
mesut sen il intéressant il ya des
points très positifs alors la marque
mais où elle va parler être des
personnes qui sont plus orientés de tête
qui connaissent vraiment le cette marque
qui arrive en france à qui arrive et il
n'y a pas très longtemps en france et
autres vers le smartphone est vraiment
intéressant il est là il est chouette
hein alors où j'aime bien moi ça c'est
minimaliste c'est très fin comme
smartphone est ce que je vous propose
c'est on se rapproche de là-bas derrière
et puis on regarde ça ensemble
alors tant que je suis là merci à orange
de m'avoir envoyé cet énorme truc c'est
un micro et yéti
voilà il ya plein de métiers par coup
moi qui voulais faire du podcast je suis
super content donc ça va me pouvoir ça
me permettre de pouvoir le faire
donc ça c'est super cool on en reparle
aussi d'ici quelques jours
merci hull et fun de m'avoir envoyé un
de ses derniers smartphones larmor 3 un
smartphone fait pour l'outdoor un
smartphone résistant il paie 69k ip68
enfin bref s'en va le prendre à secouer
un peu partout en classe et franchement
cool mais pour l'heure on parle d'eux
ça cette bête le meizu sexting la boîte
voyez je suis pas le premier à l'avoir
reçu des gens dont certains qui sont
faits les coquineries avec bravo alors
j'ai bien j'aime bien bon soit ce
classique en le le côté noir comme ça
avec le le noir en brillance et à ses
classes dans la boîte je vous montre
hyper hyper hyper rapidement là rien de
bien d'un dock là il y avait le
téléphone on arrive ça de ce côté là ce
qui est cool c'est qu'en plus mais vous
vous a mis une petite coque de
protection
alors franchement c'est pas la plus
belle c'est pas la plus sexy câble de
recharge usb vers usb t-il ses gros
blocs d'alimentation mais où donc ça
c'est cool
et puis vous avez à j'ai fait tomber ce
truc de quoi ouvrir votre tiroir de
cartes sim tant qu'on est là on va
l'ouvrir
vous allez voir qu'à l'intérieur on a la
possibilité de mettre deux cartes
nanocyl mais pas de carte microsd en
extension de mémoire le smartphone en
lui-même
moi je le trouve assez cool je trouve
que d'un point de vue design mais il
nous a franchement bien réussi sa copie
pourquoi parce que déjà il est
extrêmement fin il se prend très bien en
main vous voyez j'ai pas des mêmes
bûcheron mais ça va très très bien ça se
montrait très maintenant la main le
design est pas révolutionnaire on apple
où je dirais la samsung grande bordure
sur le aux grandes bordure sur le bas
bord très fin sur les côtés on retrouve
néanmoins ici ce petit haut parleur
comme on a notamment sur le one piece si
c'était donc ça c'est plutôt pas mal
petite caméra frontale on va détailler
dans quelques instants sur le côté c'est
aussi très épuré bouton de volume bouton
pour l'allumer ici en bas un haut
parleur de ce côté-là de l'usb type
c'est le micro une petite prise jack ça
c'est cool qui si votre carte sim on l'a
déjà vu est ici un deuxième micro qui
sape la réduction de bruit donc voilà
c'est simple c'est cool et à l'arrière
vous avez un double module photo 20 plus
de 12 mégapixels on voit les quelques
instants ça c'est le flash led alors le
flash led est juste hallucinant je vais
vous montrer comment dites fait on peut
le déverrouiller parce que vous avez un
capteur up digital directement sous
l'écran qui marche c'est pas si vous
savez comment ça marche ce truc là ça
marche ça fait de la lumière
ça vient éclairer votre doigt et celle
reconnaît cette manière là donc ce qui
fait que ça marche quand même moins vite
que les capteurs digitaux un peu
standard place à l'arrière mais celui-ci
je trouve quand même très très réactive
donc ça c'est plutôt cool et alors le
flash led vous allez voir il envoie du
bois une fois que vous l'avez regardé
vous avez mal aux yeux
en fait vous avez si laide à l'intérieur
qu'ils vont tout le tour il est clair
mais d'une façon impressionnante
c'est un des flashs elle est plus
puissant que jamais
c'est un smartphone qui disposeront de
couleur soit en blanc soit en noir il
pèse 152 g
il est léger sur le côté vous avez de
l'aluminium sur le dos et du verre c'est
sympa c'est cool c'est bien alors
maintenant à regarder un petit peu du
côté de l'écran parce que pour moi c'est
vraiment un des usages principaux sur
ses smartphones
c'est vraiment le côté multimédia et
c'est vraiment je pense en tout cas un
des points principaux peut-être le point
fort de ce smartphone vous avez un écran
samsung de 6 pouces une diagonale de 6
pouces c'est un écran super amoled avec
une résolution de 2160 parmi les 80
pixels à 402 pixels par pouce ratio 18
9e et un écran qui occupent 91,18 %
seront très précis de la façade
entendons nous bien le design de ce
smartphone n'est pas révolutionnaire à
l'écran n'est pas à révolutionnaire on
retrouve un petit peu sur les écrans que
faisait sa leçon parce qu'on a encore
les gros point d'interrogation même si
on sait à quoi ça va ressembler en 2019
on est un peu sur un design samsung jet
fin 2018 avec neo moi le fait d'avoir le
haut parleur ici qui rappelle vraiment
le one piece systech mais où fait le
choix de ne pas m'être d'encoches ce qui
va plaire à beaucoup de personnes je
vous parle de samsung
ça pue le design de samsung 2018 parce
qu'en 2019 samsung va changer sa gamme
va amener plein de nouveautés et
notamment mes différents coachs ça on le
verra on en reparlera plus tard
d'ailleurs que ça vous intéresse
abonnez-vous parce qu'on va voir ça très
très prochainement je vais partir à
barcelone au mwc voir le nouveau
smartphone de samsung sera présenté
quelques jours avant à san francisco
donc ça c'est cool par contre on usage
pur et dur au niveau du multimédia c'est
franchement un régal l'écran fonctionne
super bien une très très très belle
qualité de dalles des couleurs qui sont
vraiment maîtriser ça c'est vraiment une
des caractéristiques de l'écran super
amoled
vous pouvez obtenir croupe un peu dans
l'image pour agrandir le format écoulant
plus ce qui est génial c'est l'eau
dessus
vous avez des hauts parleurs stéréo ça
crache fort vous avez un haut parleur là
que l'eau par leur principal vous aurez
plus de gras plus de basses un deuxième
haut parleurs ici qu'il a dégagé
beaucoup moins durable il vous aurez
plus début mais ça va rajouter un pan
sensation d'immersion et c'est
franchement hyper plaisant lorsque vous
la regardez des films
tout ce que vous voulez c'est
franchement super donc ça pour moi c'est
vraiment le point numéro un sur ce
smartphone c'est l'aspect multimédia
si vous allez sur le meizu 16 vous serez
absolument pas déçu au niveau de
l'expérience multimédia elle sera pas du
tout gâcher parce que comme je vous le
dis l'écran est d'une grande qualité
l'expérience sonore est vraiment bien et
en plus de ça vous avez une prise jack
qui situe juste en dessous ce qui est
plutôt bien d'autant plus que les prises
jack disparaissent de plus en plus sont
déjà disparu des smartphones apple
elles vont très probablement disparaître
des smartphones samsung est pour
l'instant on la conserve la et la
qualité est franchement bien on a des
graves qui sont propres
ça reste quand même beaucoup dans le
médium les aigus sont pas mal c'est pas
le truc qu'on doit le plus de pression
dans l'aigu on n'a pas trop de basse de
son très grave
ça n'a pas ronronner mais je trouve que
de ce point de vue là franchement c'est
vraiment correct qui dit multimédia dit
forcément lecture de vidéos mais dit
aussi jeu vidéo est là dessus c'est vrai
que le meizu 16 est vraiment très
intéressant parce que derrière il ya la
performance
il est un dragon 845 c'était jusqu'à il
ya très peu de temps le dernier socle
plus haut de gamme de qualcomm
il est couplé soit assise giga de ram
soit à 8 gigas de ram s'il est sur une
version 6 giga de ram
vous aurez 64 giga de stockage non
extensible et sur 8 gigas de ram vous
aurez 128 giga de stockage non
extensible 60 gigas et quand même
beaucoup moins problématique alors
qu'est ce que ça vous apporte tout ça
cela vous apporter de la fluidité
lorsque vous allez jouer à des jeux dont
vous pourrez mettre des jeux qui seront
un peu plus gourmand vous allez pouvoir
vraiment profiter d'une expérience
beaucoup plus fluide notamment un jeu
comme peu ivg qui va tourner sur
beaucoup de bécanes même avec des sommes
beaucoup moins performant avec celui ci
et avec notamment au niveau technique au
niveau affichage une adreno 630 vous
allez gagner en fluidité en expérience
de jeu ça va être beaucoup plus
confortable mail ça marchera avec par
exemple un souk de la série 600 de chez
qualcomm s'écoule franchement c'est
hyper fluide ça marche bien
le fait d'avoir le son en stéréo comme
ça ça pousse ça vous donne plus
d'immersion c'est vraiment hyper hyper
hyper hyper confort et ça franchement
c'est hyper hyper aprécial si vous
intéressez à la partie spec vraiment
poussé j'ai fait un test surtout tous
les scores de 280 2311
qui est franchement très très bien
qu'ils placent parmi les meilleurs dans
sa catégorie sur un dragon 845 donc en
termes de performances pour la fluidité
pour pouvoir naviguer sur internet
naviguer dans le smartphone lorsque vous
voulez allez vous voulez franchement
vous serez absolument pas déçu
d'ailleurs puisque je vous montre un
petit peu là le smartphone je vous
parlais de l'ol on tourne sur un android
8 points et la surcouche c'est la flamme
ios 7.5 la surcouche en lui-même
elle me transcende pas les écoles je
trouve pas complètement folle vous
n'avez pas de tiroirs d'application
néanmoins ça fonctionne bien vous avez
tout un catalogue de thèmes que vous
allez pouvoir télécharger donc ça c'est
franchement cous et pouvoir choisir donc
pas mal de thèmes
ça c'est bien vous avez la navigation
soit un petit peu ce temps là avec vos
boutons soit la navigation par gestes
donc ça c'est pareil c'est aussi
franchement franchement cool
vous avez bien évidemment le plextor de
google mais vous avez aussi l'app store
de meizu avec pleins d'applications
différentes donc ça c'est aussi
intéressant ça peut être un vrai
complément par rapport justement au ps
store après en lui-même le smartphone
fonctionne bien on aime on n'aime pas
l'ouest c'est pas extrêmement gras point
qui est vraiment intéressant lorsque
vous allez avoir des sessions de jeu
prolongé lorsque vous allez utiliser de
la performance vous avez du
refroidissement liquide ce qui fait vous
n'allez pas avoir d'endroit trop chaud
au niveau d'autres smartphones vous
allez avoir une belle répartition de la
chaleur s'associe à un point très
intéressant
parlons maintenant de l'épineuse
question de l'autonomie sur le meizu 16
on a une batterie de 3010 milliampères
heures alors il ya beaucoup de marques
de smartphones qui ont des batteries pas
forcément hyper élevés ont cessé sous un
peu là la course à l'échalote on a même
des batteries 10000 euros par heure bon
on va rester calme tout dépend si l'ol
derrière qui est bien optimisé
si vous avez quelque chose qui est
vraiment optimisé ça devrait pouvoir le
faire à savoir que sur le pixel 3 que
j'utilise en ce moment on a une batterie
je lis pas de bêtises de 2800 millions
terreur l'autonomie est pas complètement
dingue sur des smartphones d'apple des
batteries qui sont peu près dans la même
taille
donc bon une batterie 3010 milan perd
heures ça me paraît pas déconner après
tout dépend de vos usages ça bien
évidemment si vous regardé beaucoup de
vidéos
si vous passez beaucoup de temps sur les
réseaux sociaux que vous poussez la
luminosité à fond le son à fond
forcément l'autonomie pas descendre
assez vite néanmoins sur un usage un peu
standard vous râlez des vidéos vous
écoutez de la musique les emails et les
photos vous bourriner pas et vous seriez
pas non plus les yeux par les occasions
de vous garder une journée
sans problème vous pouvez duré un peu
plus d'une journée
mais la journée et demie les deux jours
ça on oublie après bien évidemment vous
étés pouvoir atteindre 2 jours si vous
faites pas grand chose du passé juste
quelques coups de fil mais sur un usage
standard ça sera pas le cas il ya un
troisième visage intéressant sur ce
smartphone c'est justement la partie
photo vidéo bon je vous explique vous
avez ici un double module photo ça ne
vous aura pas échappé
vous avez un premier capteur 12
mégapixels c'est une caméra sony il ya
un 'mix' 380 le deuxième c'est également
un solide 20 mégapixels le premier c'est
un objectif grand-angle qui a une
ouverture de f 1.8 donc il fonctionne
plutôt pas mal en conditions de faible
luminosité
tandis que le deuxième c'est un
téléobjectif qui sera pas très bon
faible luminosité qui ouvre à f 2.8 mais
qui globalement fait la faire vous avez
un zoom x 3 ça je vais vous le montrer
sur le capteur principal vous avez une
stabilisation optique sur quatre axes ça
c'est plutôt bien ça permet de
déclencher des photos assez rapidement
je vous le disais le flash led qui est
extrêmement performant et à l'avant vous
avez ici une caméra 2 mégapixels qui va
ouvrir à f 2.0
d'un point de vue logiciel pour prendre
vos photos c'est assez minimaliste mais
ça fonctionne très très bien flash hd à
vous pouvez activer désactiver le
retardateur trois secondes 10 secondes
petit colorimétrie un embellissement et
quelques paramètres vous pouvez bien
évidemment tenir active est ici la
reconnaissance de scène avec lacteos
artificiel c'est justement le point dont
je vous parlais tout à l'heure avec le
stade rigaud 845 qui vous permet d'avoir
de l'intelligence artificielle beaucoup
de reconnaissance de scène et devenir
complètement optimiser vos images
ça c'est cool vous avez donc mode photo
avec un zoom optique x 3 et vous avez
ensuite un zoom numérique ou là vous
allez pouvoir carrément bien grimpé
jusqu'à 1 8 mais bon voilà c'est
extraordinaire c'est tout de suite
perdre en qualité
vous avez également un mode portrait qui
est plutôt cool de la vidéo bien
évidemment et vous pouvez choisir votre
format jusqu en 4k format 16/9 pour moi
le 1080p antivibrations sera le meilleur
compromis et ensuite vous avez des modes
supplémentaires pro panorama balayé pour
reconnaître du qr codes laps de temps le
tag l'aps et un mode ralenti donc ça
franchement c'est plutôt cool
nous voilà en vidéo ce que je propose
d'aller faire quelques clichés en
extérieur en intérieur en conditions de
bonne luminosité
et aussi aux conditions de mauvaises en
tout cas faible luminosité comme ça on
sera plus contre au final le résultat
est assez sympa la miss france s'est
fait automatiquement sur les fleurs
devant ça marche franchement plutôt pas
mal
c'est pareil je trouve que les couleurs
sont assez naturel très bien restitués
on a dû point de détail même sur cet
arbuste ou la gestion ou point vise une
fois de zoom x 3 ça marche alors voyez
une différence de couleur entre le zoom
x 2 et zoom x 3 du coup en voyant ça je
me demande même si loulou x 2 n'est pas
fait sur l'objectif principal de façon
numérique c'est très surprenant mais
c'est exactement la même couleur voyez
on retrouve vraiment les mêmes couleurs
mais dès qu'on arrive tout de suite sur
le zoom x 3 eh bien les couleurs sont
pas les mêmes sont pas restitués de la
même manière
c'est assez surprenant je me demande
comment ça marche mais bon voyage en
tout cas la qualité est quand même
relativement là si notre photo sur une
fleur pour voir qu'on est au mois de
janvier c'est quand même plutôt banal
les couleurs sont vraiment bien
restituer ce vraiment le pour moi le
point vraiment très très positif de ce
smartphone sur la caméra avant j'aime
pas le traitement salissent énormément
les visages sans la caméra de ses deux
fils à ses impôts le un peu le point de
regretter soit en faible luminosité
forcément on va perdre tout de suite en
qualité en détail on est sur la photo de
nuit
bon ça ne paraît pas déconnant en photo
vidéo où il résida qui est très proche
ça pour moi c'est vraiment un point
essentiel est un point très important
sur ces typologies de smartphones je le
trouve qu'il arrive pas au niveau du rx
17 pro duo pop par rapport aux moines pu
assister un peu plus compliqué je ne
trouve pas mal pour moi le résultat est
propre
on n'est pas sur un truc complètement
fou negras derrière à la performance du
soc le qualcomm snapdragon 845
l'intelligence artificielle ce qui vous
permet d'avoir la reconnaissance de
scène on va vraiment optimisé les images
bon voilà je trouve que dans l'absolu ça
fonctionne plutôt bien
il est assez équilibré du point de vue
multimédia du point de vue je gaming aux
règles générales du point de vue photo
du point de vue et expériences c'est
plutôt pas mal pour le déverrouiller
vous avez bien évidemment le capteur
d'empreintes digitales directement
intégrés sous l'écran mais vous avez
aussi la reconnaissance de visages qui
franchement est très rapide marche très
bien et ça c'est aussi un point
extrêmement positif ça déverrouille
instantanément vous avez également du
bluetooth 5.0 par contre ce que je vais
regretter sur ce smartphone c'est qu'il
n'y ait pas de nfc alors même si tout le
monde ne va pas à payer avec son
smartphone
c'est quand même dommage sur un
smartphone fin 2018 même petit carrément
2019 ne pas avoir de l'ex intérieur pour
flagship parce qu'on parle très
clairement du smartphone haut de gamme
de meizu donc ne pas avoir mis de fc
pour moi c'est un peu une erreur
stratégique
deuxième erreur stratégique c'est le
fait de ne pas avoir de carte micro sd
pour pouvoir rajouter du stockage photo
vidéo 64 giga en natif comme j'aime dans
ce smartphone là c'est déjà bien mais si
vous êtes un gros consommateur de
musique de photos et vidéos ça peut à un
moment ou à un autre coin c'est d'autant
plus que 64 giga vous les avez il faut
enlever un peu d espace pour l'eau est à
l'intérieur
donc en réalité vous ne disposez pas de
64 giga pour moi c'est un smartphone qui
vient en concurrence avec le one piece
6t en termes de tarifs il est plutôt pas
mal placée notamment sur la
configuration si giga de ram 64 giga de
stockage où trouver à 449 euros 90
centimes et sur une config 8 gigas de
ram 128 géant du stockage où le trouver
à 549 euros 90 mais aussi plutôt bien
placé est ce qu'au final ce meizu 16 est
intéressant est ce qu'il faut l'acheter
oui ou non et puis au final pourquoi
choisir plutôt qu'un autre alors c'est
toujours un peu compliqué parce que dans
cette gamme de prix autour des 500 euros
il ya quand même pas mal de produits et
des marques très fortes qui compte
notamment owen plus ce qui est vraiment
monté en puissance depuis quelques
années vous allez aussi shiomi cas
d'excellents produits pompes au cad
excellent produit et puis bisou qui va
s'offrir un petit peu de son image de
marque en france parce que c'est quand
même ma qui n'est pas particulièrement
connu
il est donc vrai que si vous cherchez un
smartphone dans un budget de 450 euros à
550 euros
on n'a pas forcément tout de suite se
diriger chemise ou néanmoins je trouve
que ce smartphone a vraiment très très
bons atouts il est rapide il ya une
autonomie qui est correct sans être
complètement hallucinante il fait des
photos qui sont franchement très honnête
il sera super bien pour regarder des
films des vidéos sur netflix sur youtube
pour jouer à des jeux vous offrira une
très bonne expérience personnellement je
vous conseillerais après j'ai vraiment
peur qu'ils souffrent un petit peu de
cette marque qui n'est pas connu ou très
peu connu plus connu par des
technophiles que par d'autres personnes
donc si cette marque vous plaît si vous
êtes tenté par acheter ce produit
et si vous trouvez un tarif intéressant
par rapport à d'autres marques comme one
plus comme au pot comme chez oh oui
pourquoi pas aller sur le meizu 16 le
mail 12,6 teens ça peut aussi être une
bonne alternative
c'est ce produit vous intéresse je vous
mets un lien en bas dans la description
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous connaissiez
marquez ou est ce que c'est en tout cas
un produit qui pourrait vous intéresser
comment vous le situer par rapport aux
autres produits un peu phare de ce
marché dans cette gamme de prix aux
pochons me one plus
et puis plein d'autres nous dites moi ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
n'oubliez pas d'aller consulter j'ai
plein de vidéos hyper intéressant sur
des tests de smartphones sur plein de
choses je vous mets le lien qui va
paraître par ici par ici par ici
d'ici là soyez sages en ce moment très
très très vite t'embrasse pour le soin
de vous